[Musique]
maintenant vous savez maintenant vous
savez pourquoi j'ai voulu que
françois-xavier bellamy puisse porter
nos couleurs
[Applaudissements]
ici mes amis ici c'est la maison et si
c'est la maison ici c'est la maison des
républicains ici dans les alpes
maritimes c'est la maison de notre
famille politique il n'ya pas d'autres
départements où les racines des
républicains sont plus profondes
il n'y a pas d'autres non il n'y a pas
d'autres départements dans lesquels nous
avons autant de militants il n'y a pas
avons autant d'élus il n'y a pas
d'autres départements qui nous ait
soutenus du cette façon aussi
indéfectible tout le temps ne l'oublions
pas et c'est moi qui le dis ici c'est la
maison mais bien sûr que celui qui vient
d'auvergne rhône alpes est indigné à
l'idée que ce soit la première
fédération notre famille politique
mais oui c'est bien la première
fédération de notre famille politique et
je vous en suis infiniment reconnaissant
parce que ici même dans les moments les
plus difficiles
j'ai toujours trouvé un point d'appui
ici je n'oublie pas quand je me suis
lancé dans cette campagne pour refonder
notre famille que vous m'avez accueilli
avec chaleur avec espoir et avec
enthousiasme et que vous m'avez dit à ce
moment là tu m'en souviens encore dans
cette belle salle où vous étiez vous
aussi tous présents on va reconstruire
et on sera à vos côtés et on va le faire
et on n'aura de cesse que d'être allé
jusqu'au bout de nos idées
comme je suis rentré dans cette salle et
que je vous ai vu aussi nombreux vous
n'imaginez pas ce que ça représente pour
moi ce que ça représente pour chacun
d'entre nous comme soutien de votre part
parce que c'est une façon très simple
mais si forte de nous dire ne la fait
pas eh bien je veux bien que vous
comprenez que je ne le ferai jamais et
je ne lâcherai pas
je ne lâcherai pas pas uniquement parce
que je veux rebâtir notre famille je ne
lâcherai pas pas uniquement parce que je
suis convaincu qu'il faut que nous
puissions revenir aux responsabilités en
ayant tiré les leçons des erreurs que
nous avons pu commettre par le passé je
ne lâcherai pas uniquement pour cela je
ne lâcherai pas parce que je suis
convaincu que nous avons une mission que
nous avons une responsabilité à l'égard
de notre pays que nous avons un chemin
que nous devons tracer et au bout duquel
nous ne sommes pas encore allés et quand
je rentre dans cette salle aux côtés de
françois xavier aux côtés d'eric aux
côtés de michel aux côtés de gens que je
retrouve tous les amis qui sont ici il
ya une chose qui me marque
ne vous y trompez pas il n'y a aucune
autre famille politique qui dans cette
campagne des européennes est capable de
faire ce que nous faisons ce soir depuis
que nous sommes entrés en campagne il y
a une seule liste qui a bousculé les
pronostics il y a une seule liste qui
semaine après semaine jour après jour et
monte petit à petit a imposé petit à
petit cette dynamique il y a une seule
liste kane dynamique dans cette campagne
des européennes c'est la liste des
républicains c'est la liste de l'union
de la droite et du centre
vous pouvez en être fier parce que c'est
le résultat de notre travail
[Applaudissements]
mais si nous allons un peu au delà c'est
plus que cela
g
suis convaincu que nos compatriotes ne
veulent pas d'une chose ils ne veulent
pas qu'on leur confie ce que leur voix
ils ne veulent pas qu'on décide à leur
place comme on le fait depuis si
longtemps dans notre pays ils en ont
assez qu'on leur explique ce qu'on a le
droit de penser ce qu'on n'a pas le
droit de dire il ne supporte plus que la
démocratie en france se résume à d'un
côté les populistes et de l'autre les
progressistes les français veulent
retrouver le choix ils ne veulent pas
être enfermé à nouveau dans cette
réédition funeste du second tour de la
présidentielle les français ne veulent
pas se retrouver pris entre d'un côté le
chaos de marine le pen et de l'autre la
déception des manuels macron et si
jamais les choses sont en train de
bouger du côté de la liste des
républicains
c'est parce que les français ont compris
que le seul endroit où il pouvait y
avoir un choix qu'il retrouve ses du
côté des républicains
la démocratie c'est le choix et nous ne
nous laisserons pas confisquer ce soit
[Applaudissements]
parce que des deux côtés
ce sont deux impasses et la réalité
d'ailleurs c'est qu'il se soutiennent
l'un et l'autre chacun d'une part et de
l'autre du précipice au dessus duquel
ils font danser notre démocratie
vous avez d'un côté marine le pen et
marine le pen est une impasse parce que
ce que propose marine le pen pour
l'europe c'est la déconstruction de
l'europe ce que propose marine le pen
c'est de mettre à bas tout ce que nos
prédécesseurs compte édifier ce qu'elle
propose c'est de sortir de l'union
européenne ce qu'elle propose c'est de
sortir de l'euro dans un pays qui a
autant de dettes dans un pays qui a
autant de déficit mais sortir de l'euro
certains qui sont ici s'en souviennent
cela veut dire une seule chose
cela veut dire une dévaluation monétaire
cela veut dire qu'un jour vous vous
réveillez que votre patrimoine a fondu
et que votre pouvoir d'achat a été
réduit ce que propose marine le pen
c'est la déconstruction de l'europe
et si je la combat de toutes mes forces
dans cette élection européenne
c'est parce que je suis convaincu que
pour la france ce serait une sortie de
l'histoire
je ne veux pas de cela pour la france je
ne veux pas de ce destin et comment ne
pas le comprendre quand il suffit
aujourd'hui de regarder de l'autre côté
de la manche pour voir la catastrophe et
le cas aucun stade le break site
ce que propose marine le pen c'est une
impasse
mais ce que propose emmanuel macron de
l'autre côté c'est tout autant une
impasse parce que comme françois-xavier
l'a très bien dit de l'autre côté
emmanuel macron n'a pas compris que nous
croyons dans l'europe mais nous voulons
remettre l'europe dans le bon chemin
nous croyons dans l'europe mais nous
sommes convaincus que l'europe petit à
petit s'est écarté de ce qu'était sa
mission initiale qu elle l europe des
manuels macron mais c'est toujours plus
de l'europe qui ne marche pas emmanuel
macron propose d'étendre encore
l'élargissement comme s'il n'y avait pas
suffisamment de pays différents qui sont
autour de la table
et comme si cela n'avait pas bi abouti à
affaiblir durablement la construction
européenne dans chacun de ses discours
emmanuel macron propose toujours plus de
bureaucratie bruxelloise
quand vous faites l'addition il a
proposé jusqu'à 15 agences
supplémentaires et la création de quatre
impôts supplémentaires à bruxelles
c'est toute l'europe dont nous ne
voulons pas il n'a pas compris qu'il
fallait quoi qu'il fallait refonder
l'europe est le plus grave dans tout
cela c'est qu'il isole petit à petit la
france soyons honnêtes
quand il a été élu il y a eu un élan
d'intérêt les autres pays européens
et d'ailleurs nous pousse nous nous
sommes dit et s'il faisait le travail
et puis nos partenaires européens l'ont
vu faire et ils ont compris assez
rapidement quelque chose et je me
souviens d'une conversation que j'ai eue
à l'époque avec angela merkel qui me
disaient nous on n'écoute pas les
discours des présidents de la république
on regarde leur premier budget est bien
ce que nos partenaires européens ont
compris c'est quoi ce qu'ils ont compris
c'est que le président parlait il
espérait un président qui réformerait et
ils ont compris que le président parlait
et qu'il se contentait de parler et l'
enthousiasme a laissé place à la
déception et nous ne sommes aliéné nos
partenaires italiens auxquels nous avons
fait la leçon et nous nous sommes aliéné
les partenaires d'europe centrale
auxquels nous avons fait la leçon en
leur expliquant qu'ils avaient tort de
vouloir arrêter les vagues d'immigration
et nous nous sommes aliéné nos
partenaires scandinave auquel nous avons
fait la leçon et nous ont répondu
mais qui êtes vous vous qui êtes le
dernier de la classe et qui avait le
pire déficit budgétaire de toute la zone
euro et vous voulez donner des leçons
aux autres mais commencez par faire des
économies sur la dépense publique
vous qui avait été incapable en deux ans
de diminuer votre dette
seul pays au sein de la zone euro à ne
pas avoir été capable de réduire sa
dette
ne vous y trompez pas quand un pays ne
fait pas d'économies sur sa dépense
publique
à l'arrivée d'une manière ou d'une autre
il le prend dans votre poche
les cadeaux d'aujourd'hui seront les
impôts de demain
et une des garanties que nous nous
apportons c'est qu'avec notre liste des
républicains de l'union de la droite et
du centre
nous nous inscrivons dans le plus grand
groupe parlementaire du parlement
européen et ça c'est une fierté pour
chacun d'entre vous nous sommes à
l'intérieur de la grande tradition du
parti populaire européen
la grande tradition du gaullisme et de
la démocratie chrétienne c'est notre
famille politique qui a édifié l'europe
quand les français votent pour notre
liste ils votent pour une voix forte de
la france allait celle de bruxelles
quand ils votent pour en mars ils votent
pour une proposition dans laquelle le
président de la république propose
d'isoler les députés français dans un
tout petit groupe qui sera un des tous
plus petits groupes allaient celle du
parlement européen et bien moi quand on
est la france je veux que l'on soit en
première division
je ne veux pas que l'on condamne la voix
de la france au silence
alors oui nous avons une immense
responsabilité refonder l'europe pour
établir la france est pour
cette refondation j'ai voulu un nouveau
souffle et je remercie ceux qui m'ont
accompagné dans ce choix
je voudrais d'ailleurs rendre hommage à
jean parce que l'un des premiers avec
lequel j'ai échangé dessus ces gens est
un des premiers à m'avoir encouragé à me
dire laurent fait le choix du
renouvellement fait le choix d'une
nouvelle génération sétois jean avec une
démarche qui teneur toi qui a été un si
bon ministre des affaires européennes et
qui a si bien défendu notre famille
politique
merci jean merci à toi et pour cette
refondation j'ai souhaité que ce soit
françois xavier qui porte nos couleurs
avec ce trio qui est à ses côtés
agnès evren arnaud danjean cette jeune
génération ses talents qu'on doit faire
monter quand on s'occupe d'une famille
politique il faut faire monter les
meilleurs il ne faut pas étouffer les
talents c'est une erreur que nous avons
si souvent fait par le passé et je vais
vous dire ce que j'ai aimé et ce que
j'aime dans ce qui porte tous ensemble
dans ce que porte françois xavier
d'abord la première chose c'est une
droite de valeur vous l'avez vu qu'il ne
s'excuse pas de ses idées on ne
reconstruira jamais notre famille
politique
si nous continuons à baisser le regard
et à marcher à l'ombre
jamais cela nous a réussi la droite
réussit quand elle porte la fierté et la
dignité de ses valeurs et de ses
convictions
et la deuxième chose c'est que ça
redonne un peu de hauteur
vous savez quand il ya eu ce débat
france télévisions et que chacun des
candidats devaient sortir un objet
symbolique de ce qu'il pensait de
l'europe et au fur et à mesure que
chacune des têtes de lit sortait un
objet je me disais mais comment la
politique at elle pu tomber aussi bas
le représentant du rassemblement
national sortait une passoire rouge
le rassemblement de ceux ne sait même
plus quelle liste avait sorti une paire
de menottes sur lequel il avait mis des
autocollants jaunes
la représentante de la liste en marche
avait sorti une petite boîte de piment
d'espelette j'adore le piment
d'espelette mais enfin honnêtement pour
incarner sa vision de l'europe peut-être
qu'il y avait autre chose à faire
et à chaque marche on descendait un peu
plus bas et françois-xavier lui nous a
heureusement redonner notre honneur lui
il a sorti un livre et quels livres 7 et
l'iliade d'homère
merci françois xavier de nous tirer vers
le haut et ceux dont j'ai toujours été
convaincu c'est qu'on peut affirmer ses
convictions tout en rassemblant on peut
affirmer ses convictions tout en
rayonnant certains croient qu'il faut
qu'on renonce à ce que nous sommes pour
pouvoir tendre la main
certains croient que quand on défend ses
idées et ses valeurs on serait précis et
bien moi je crois tout l' inverse
je crois que quand on défend ses idées
quand on les explique au grand jour
c'est à ce moment là que l'on peut
rassembler regardez l'image aujourd'hui
de notre famille politique
ils sont tous là tout le monde est
présent le premier auquel je veux rendre
hommage c'est eric vous le savez dans
une démarche de reconstruction c'est
très difficile
c'est une démarche qui est ardue et j'ai
besoin de compter sur des personnes qui
sont là raconte les sondages sont hauts
comme sur des personnes qui sont là
quand les sondages son bord eric il est
toujours avec moi je n'ai jamais besoin
de me retourner
je sais que je peux compter sur sa
confiance son engagement et sa
détermination merci à toi et merci il ya
missel ici quand nous avons lancé ce
mensonge michel nous avons longuement
parlé tous les deux et j'apprécie c'est
toi cette droiture et cette loyauté
indéfectible qui vient puiser dans
l'histoire de ta famille de ta famille
personnelle merci michel depuis que nous
avons cheminé ensemble qui a toujours
été là et je suis très reconnaissante de
ta présence encore une fois ici il y à
tous ceux qui sont venus charles ange
qui veille sur votre département
il y à nos parlementaires j'espère
n'oublier personne
henri bernard kohl est laurent jean
pierre éric dominique applaudissent et
l'ethos parce qu'il le mérite
il y à nos mères
sébastien christian louis david jérôme
lionel jeanclaude pour ceux qui sont ici
et qui incarne également notre fierté et
j'aime quand notre famille politique et
rassembler comme elle est ainsi et
j'aime quand on avance soudés comme on
l'est est ainsi pourquoi parce que dans
cette campagne nous sommes les seuls à
parler d'europe
les autres parlent de bruxelles les
autres parlent de l'union européenne les
autres parlent d'une construction
administrative certains parlent de
souverainisme d'autres parlent de
fédéralisme mais qui parle de l'europe
nous sommes les seuls à parler de
l'europe parce que l'europe c'est autre
chose
l'europe c'est une âme
l'europe c'est un projet c'est un projet
de civilisation quand les pères
fondateurs
au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale quand toute l'europe a été
détruite par la barbarie nazie décide
donc lancé ce projet qui était fou à
l'époque de construire l'union des
nations
là où il n'y avait eu que de la haine et
des morts que font-ils sur ce drapeau
ils choisissent de mettre les étoiles de
la couronne de la vierge
il met les étoiles de la couronne de la
vierge landes où un seul instant que ce
soit à projet de civilisation et
comptines à ce moment comme question
françois xavier
c'est celle que tu as si bien résumé
est-ce que ce que nous sommes a encore
un avenir ce qu'ils font à ce moment là
c'est qu'ils veulent montrer que la
reconstruction de l'europe n'aboutira
pas à la disparition de la voix de
l'europe ce qu'ils veulent montrer à ce
moment là c'est que nous ne dépendrons
pas des américains et que l'europe va
reconstruire petit à petit son
indépendance et son autonomie
c'est ce chemin qu'ils construisent à ce
moment là et nous pourquoi êtes vous là
parce que vous
vous posez tous la même question est-ce
qu'on a un avenir
est ce que la voix de l'europe un avenir
est ce qu'on peut lui redonner un
souffle est-ce que nous sommes condamnés
à assister à ce que notre continent
change de nature christophe
silencieusement ou est-ce que nous
pouvons redonner ce souffle à la
civilisation européenne
alors quand on vous interrogera en vous
demandant quelle europe
voulez-vous et bien l'europe que nous
voulons c'est celle qui inspirait
confiance parce qu'elle savait qui elle
était l'europe que nous voulons bernard
c'est l'europe puissance qui n'hésite
pas à défendre ses intérêts l'europe que
nous voulons c'est celle qui marchait
qui fonctionnait et qui nous donnait
notre fierté
l'europe que nous voulons c'est l'europe
projet l'europe pour laquelle nous nous
battons c'est l'europe civilisation
quand on vous demande quelle europe
voulez vous répondez nous voulons
l'europe de la civilisation et de
l'identité
c'est cette europe pour laquelle nous
nous engageons une civilisation une
civilisation d'abord ce sont des
frontières quand romulus et rémus fonde
rome il trace un sillon pour marquer
clairement que ce sont eux qui
décideront ce qu'ils rentreront à
l'intérieur de la cité romaine
l'europe c'est des frontières des
frontières ça veut dire qu'il y a des
limites et que l'europe ne peut pas
s'étendre à l'infini une de nos
différences majeures avec la liste dans
marche c'est que le président de la
république a proposé à prix y est que
les pays des balkans intègre l'union
européenne une de notre différence
majeure par rapport aux projets des
manuels macron sait qu emmanuel macron a
accepté que les négociations avec
l'albanie l'albanie s'ouvre en juin
comme par hasard au lendemain de
l'élection européenne
eh bien nous tous ceux qui sont sur
notre liste et le savent
franck prennent avec moi un engagement
ils voteront contre toute décision
pendant leur mandat qui ouvrirait la
voie à tout élargissement
supplémentaires
d'autres élargissements supplémentaires
et nous portons de concert avec la cdu
ou notre partenaire allemand une
revendication claire on arrête une bonne
fois pour toutes les négociations avec
la turquie la turquie ça n'est pas dans
l'union européenne et en arrête ce
cinéma avec lequel on vit depuis trop
longtemps
[Applaudissements]
connaître ses frontières c'est bien
défendre ses frontières
c'est tout aussi important oui le défi
migratoire est devant nous
oui comme tu l'as si bien rappelé le
gouvernement depuis deux ans n'a rien
fait pire que cela jamais notre pays n'a
délivré autant de titres de séjour plus
de deux cent cinquante mille titres de
séjour chaque année supplémentaire qui
sont délivrés ce qui représente
l'équivalent d'une ville de bordeaux
chaque année notre pays et le continent
européen ne peut pas faire face à une
telle l'immigration
nous avons dépassé nos capacités
d'intégration et nous devons de toute
urgence reprendre la maîtrise de la
politique migratoire
cela suppose de maîtriser à la fois ses
frontières européennes et ses frontières
nationales
je suis allé à vintimille pour aller
discuter avec les policiers qui essayent
de vrais tant bien que mal pour protéger
notre frontière à cet endroit avec
l'italie je suis allé en grèce pour
discuter avec les policiers les
gardes-frontières qui essayent tant bien
que mal pour lutter contre l'immigration
qui nous vient de turquie
c'est le même travail c'est la même
cause
c'est la même mission l'erreur que
commet marine le pen c'est qu'elle dit
il ne faut pas que ce soit l'europe qui
défendent nos frontières mais enfin
comment ne peut-elle pas comprendre que
quand ils rentrent par la grèce quand
ils rentrent par l'italie quand ils
rentrent par l'espagne ensuite il arrive
en france et que donc il est
indispensable qu'il y ait un travail
commun européen pour défendre nos
frontières européennes
cette indispensable
mais avec une clarté
l'objectif ce n'est pas d'accueillir les
bateaux des passeurs sur le continent
européen
c'est de les reconduire sur les côtes
africaines l'objectif ça n'est pas
d'avoir le double discours que tient le
ministre de l'intérieur qui chaque
semaine qui vient faire un peu plus sa
crédibilité
un ministre de l'intérieur qui déclarent
un jour que les ong sont complices des
passeurs et qui cinq jours plus tard
décide d'accueillir les migrants du
bateau cia y
mais comment peut-on croire à ce double
discours permanent nous le nôtre est
très claire les bateaux des passeurs
doivent être reconduits sur les côtes
africaines
les demandes mais demande d'asile
doivent être faites sur les côtes
africaines et non pas en europe parce
que quand les demandes d'asile sont
faites en europe c'est trop tard et
quand la justice dit que les gens n'ont
pas à rester en france
ils ne sont jamais reconduit à
l'étranger et donc c'est trop tard quand
les demandes d'asile sont faites chez
nous elles doivent être faite de l'autre
côté de la méditerranée et enfin il faut
sortir de cette prime à l'illégalité
quand un étranger venu irrégulièrement
en europe s'il est ensuite régularisés
et bien c'est un encouragement à bafouer
les règles et les lois de l'europe
adoptons le même principe simple et
clair qui est été adopté par l'australie
si quelqu'un est rentré irrégulièrement
sur le continent européen
il ne peut plus jamais être régularisés
parce que sinon on encourage ceux qui
bafouent nos propres règles et nos
propres lois
[Applaudissements]
et ceci mes amis ceux ci j'en suis
convaincu c'est la seule chose qui
permet de redonner aussi un avenir à
l'afrique je ne sous-estime rien des
drames je ne sous-estime rien de la
souffrance de ces visages qu'on voit
parfois la frontière des visages hagards
qui ont fait parfois des milliers de
kilomètres pour arriver ici en étant des
racines et sans doute en ayant vécu des
choses terribles qui ont été amenées
parfois à saigner leur famille pour
pouvoir payer les passeurs et les mafias
qui les ont instrumentalisé et bien mes
amis je vous le dis la vraie générosité
la vraie générosité comme le disait si
bien peggy la vraie générosité c'est la
fermeté est rien et meurtriers comme la
lâcheté notre devoir c'est de faire en
sorte que le développement soit en
afrique
notre devoir c'est d'aider le
développement humanitaire en afrique
notre devoir c'est de dire que l'avenir
de la jeunesse africaine est en afrique
ça c'est notre devoir
[Applaudissements]
une civilisation ensuite ce sont des
ambitions communes
françois-xavier l'a si bien dit le
travail
l'europe des projets pas celle des
normes je n'y reviendrai pas l'europe de
la santé jean pour laquelle tu te bats
une europe qui soit capable de faire
travailler ensemble nos laboratoires de
recherche pour lutter contre la maladie
d'alzheimer
cette europe que nous avons vu cet
après-midi et dont vous êtes un reflet
une europe qui croient dans l'audace une
europe qui croient dans le souffle une
europe qui croient dans l'initiative
cette europe qui s'est incarné avec ces
quelques visages croisés cet après midi
que j'ai tellement aimé
quant à sophia antipolis sur le site de
biotech
vous avez un jeune qui a été formé au
bts de chimie de nice et qui vient nous
voir et qui nous dit moi je suis fier de
mon travail
j'adore la chimie c'est ma passion je
veux que l'europe puisse continuer à
découvrir des médicaments et les remèdes
de demain pour continuer à faire
progresser la santé mais qu'est ce que
ça fait du bien de voir quelqu'un qui
aime son travail
il croit dans ce qu'il fait et qui en
est fier quand on était david sur le
chantier de ce super de campus
universitaires que vous êtes tous
entrain de bâtir avec cette belle
coopération entre les communes sur ce
site de cannes où vous allez faire un
des plus beaux campus universitaire qui
va permettre demain de forme et
peut-être les scénaristes de geniki
redresseront l'industrie du cinéma
européen et français et qu'il y ait un
chef de chantier qui vient et qui nous
dit venez avec moi je vais vous montrer
mon béton regardez comme il est beau et
comme on a fait un beau travail
c'est cette europe que j'aime c'est
celle du travail c'est pas celle des
normes
c'est une europe qui ne croient pas au
fait que l'on devienne un pays un
continent où poussent des caddies à
acheter des produits qui ont été fait
partout ailleurs sauf chez nous je crois
à l'europe du travail dans une europe
dans laquelle tout n'est pas à acheter
dans lequel le corps humain n'est pas
une marchandise et dans laquelle on
reprend confiance et où on comprend que
le vrai social c'est le travail
je ne veux pas d'une europe dans lequel
plus personne ne veut travailler et
c'est pour cela que je revendique que
chez nous il y ait toujours un équilibre
entre les droits et les devoirs et que
quand on bénéficie de la solidarité
nationale
on puisse aussi travaillé pour rendre
une partie de ce qu'on a reçu et enfin
mes amis je finirai par là une
civilisation c'est une identité
c'est une tradition c'est une culture
commune
cette tradition
identité cette civilisation comment ne
pas voir qu'elle est aujourd'hui menacée
elle est menacée c'est sans doute le
plus grave pour nous elle est menacé par
des gens qui parfois sont nés sur le
continent européen
elle est menacé par des gens auxquels
nous avons tout donné
auxquels l'europe a offert toute sa
générosité et qui ont tourné leur haine
et leur arme contre ce que nous sommes
et qui déteste
aujourd'hui tout ce que nous avons voulu
leur transmettre la guerre contre
l'islamisme est une guerre dans laquelle
il ne peut pas y avoir de répit ni de
l'acheter la guerre contre l'islamisme à
l'est celle de l'europe suppose de
prendre les mesures qui s'imposent les
mesures qui s'imposent ce sont des
mesures de fermeté enfin c'est pour cela
que nous proposons qu'il y ait un pacte
européen contre l'islamisme que ce pacte
européen contre l'islamisme reposent sur
des décisions de bon sens la première
décision de bon sens s'est d'abord de
fermer toutes les mosquées salafistes
qui sont en europe
d'autres les mosquées salafistes qui
sont en europe
la deuxième mesure qui s'impose c'est
celle d'empêcher aux imams qui prêchent
la haine de continuer à prêcher tous les
vendredis comment pouvons nous accepter
qu'il continue à faire cela comme nous
le faisons eric michel gens quand la
république instaurée la laïcité elle a
fait preuve de fermeté et la religion
catholique a été capable de comprendre
qu'elle devait s'adapter à ce que
demandait la république eh bien il est
évident que nous devons faire preuve de
la même fermeté à l'égard dépresseurs de
n est que nous devons leur interdire de
continuer à prêcher leur travail de sape
et de propagande à l'ombre des mots
spring
et enfin mes amis comment comprendre que
le gouvernement français a accepté de
faire revenir sur le sol français 200
jihadistes nous revendiquons qu'il y ait
un travail qu'ils soient très claires de
la part de l'europe que l'europe oeuvre
en lien avec l'irak pour qu'il y ait un
tribunal international qui soit
installée en irak que ce tribunal
international permettent de juger les
djihadistes qui ont commis leur crime en
irak et en syrie
là-bas qu'il soit condamné sur le sol
irakien et qu'ils restent sur le sol
irakien
ils ont trahi la france et l'europe ils
ne doivent pas revenir en france et en
europe
et parce que je n'aime pas les faux
semblants
je veux aussi que vous sachiez qu'aucune
de ces mesures n'a été soutenu par
marine le pen
quant au niveau du parlement européen
une proposition a été faite pour faire
en sorte que l'europe se dote d'un
logiciel permettant de suivre et de
détecter les mouvements des terroristes
pour les empêcher notamment de pouvoir
embarquer dans des aéroports
marine le pen a refusé de voter cette
disposition et a expliqué qu'elle ne le
faisait pas parce que les terroristes ne
prenez pas l'avion
honte à marine le pen d'avoir osé dire
cela après les attentats du 11 septembre
il y à bien deux visages sur le front
national pour marine le pen
elle est tellement contre l'europe
qu'elle est contre l'europe y compris
quand elles y sacrifie les intérêts de
la france madame le pen évidemment que
les terroristes prennent l'avion
les frères kouachi avait pris l'avion et
les terroristes qui ont envoyé ces
avions contre les tours des twin towers
à new york
qu'avait-il prix comment peut-on être à
ce point là irresponsables et
incompétents
[Applaudissements]
retenir la leçon de notre dame
françois-xavier retrouver le droit
d'aimer ce que nous sommes
comment at-on pu en arriver là
comment ne peut-on pas comprendre qu'une
civilisation aussi merveilleuse que la
nôtre qu'une culture aussi merveilleuse
que la nôtre issus de trois racines tout
aussi estimable les racines de
l'antiquité les racines judéo
chrétiennes les racines des lumières
comment ne pas comprendre que notre
devoir c'est de la transmettre
nous sommes ici au bord de la
méditerranée vous avez toute légitimité
à être infiniment fier de ce que
représente ce petit bout de terre
européenne et son apport unique
vous êtes les héritiers d'une fondation
qui a été fait par des colons grecs qui
ont étendu la démocratie et qu'il entend
installer ici sur ces petits bords de la
méditerranée vous êtes les héritiers de
ce fruit extraordinaire de l' empire
romain qui avait fait de cette petite
partie de l' empire romain un de ses
joyaux qui était à l'époque appelé la
provincia romana vous êtes les héritiers
de ce mouvement magnifique qui est
partie ici de saint-honorat comme tu me
le rappelait de ce mouvement cisterciens
parti d'ici et qui a permis petit à
petit de christianiser toute l'europe et
de la couvrir de ce manteau d'églises et
de cathédrales qui font que quand nous
nous déplaçons dans un autre pays et que
l'on reconnaît un clocher que l'on
reconnaît la silhouette familière d'une
cathédrale
on sait alors qu'on est en europe vous
êtes les héritiers de ceux qui dans une
terre hostile ont lutté contre les
barbaresques ont lutté contre les
pirateries n'ont jamais renoncé en
systématiquement reconstruit les
villages qui avait été détruit et qui
avait été attaqué vous êtes le fruit
magnifique de ce mouvement séculaire
avec lequel petit à petit la france est
édifié et la france a su qu'elle était
au bout de la démarche de construction
de l'état nation
quand enfin le comté de nice avait
intégré la république et la nation
française avec le travail qui avait été
fait à l'époque
le second empire vous êtes les héritiers
de tout cela vous êtes les héritiers de
cette lumière magique qui a illuminé les
peintres français et qui leur ont permis
ensuite d'émerveiller le monde c'est pas
un prix extraordinaire bonnart bien sûr
matisse chagall les impressionnistes qui
ont ici appris à chérir la lumière
unique qui existe dans la méditerranée
évidemment pas seulement l'été mais dans
ces moments extraordinaires de
transition entre deux saisons où tout
d'un coup quand on tourne le regard vers
la grande bleue
on est ébloui par cette lumière unique
au monde vous êtes les héritiers de tout
cela vous êtes les héritiers aussi de
cette audace extraordinaire qui est
celle de cette terre qui n'avait rien
pour réussir et qui est petit à petit
devenu un eldorado
au nom de quoi aurions-nous honte de ce
que nous sommes
au nom de quoi aurions-nous honte de
notre mode de vie nous avons toute
légitimité à être fiers nous avons
toutes les imitent imiter a demandé que
cette histoire cette culture ce mode de
vie soit respectée parce qu'ils viennent
sur le continent européen et qui
viennent en terre française
et oui françois-xavier tu l'as dit il y
à des incendies comme l' incendie de
notre dame
mais il ya aussi des incendies plus
invisible il y à des destructions plus
silencieuse il y à des destructions
qu'elle nous ne prêtons pas garde
parce qu'elles ne font pas
nécessairement la une de l'actualité et
pour autant elles sont tout aussi graves
quand on accepte que dans une salle de
classe on ne puisse plus faire un voyage
à reims parce qu'on explique que ça
n'est pas compatible avec la religion de
certains cantons acceptent que dans une
salle de classe
on ne puisse plus enseigner l'histoire
de la shoah alors c'est un petit
incendie
quand un président de la république va
de l'autre côté de la rive de la
méditerranée et que insultant ainsi la
mémoire de bien des familles qui ont
tout perdu
il explique qu'en algérie la france
n'aurait commis que des crimes contre
l'humanité alors nous renonçons à une
petite partie de ce que nous sommes
comme dans un hôpital on accepte qu'une
femme ne puisse pas être soigné par un
médecin homme parce que son mari
explique que ce n'est pas compatible
avec sa religion
quand un de nos dans un de nos quartiers
une femme n'a pas le choix et qu'elle
doit se couvrir la tête parce que
certains décident à sa place ce qu'est
sa liberté ce qui est son droit ce qui
est sa légitimité à travailler ou non
cette un petit incendie à chaque fois
que nous reculons sur un bout de notre
identité et de ce que nous sommes c'est
un petit bout d'un incendie
pourquoi est-ce que je n'ai jamais voulu
céder sur cette question en apparence
anecdotique des crèches
parce que je suis convaincu qu'à chaque
fois que l'on recule c'est un petit bout
de ce que nous sommes que nous perdons
je ne veux plus que nous reculions je ne
veux plus que nous reculions alors oui
mes amis
il faut retrouver le vrai sens de
l'intégration ce sens de l'intégration
merveilleux donc plusieurs ici pourrait
témoigner et qui a fait que la france
l'europe a été capable d'accueillir des
générations qui venaient de l'étranger
et qui venaient en disant ce mot
merveilleux à leurs enfants
à compter de ce jour ton pays c'est la
france
ton continent c'est l'europe nous avons
commis une erreur funeste
en inversant le devoir d'intégration et
en croyant que la tolérance c'était au
contraire nous de changer
c'est exactement l'inversé qu'il faut
faire la vraie tolérance la vraie
générosité c'est d'expliquer à ceux qui
viennent ce qu'est notre mode de vie
c'est de leur transmettre notre culture
et de notre histoire et de leur dire à
compter de ce jour c'est la vôtre et
vous devez la respecter oui mes amis
c'est cela notre bataille
c'est cela notre combat notre combat
c'est de rappeler à chacun de nos
habitants à chacun des pays européens
qu'ils sont les héritiers de cette
grande histoire et de cette belle
culture et que d'être un héritier
c'est à la fois une source de fierté et
qu'en même temps ça oblige nous devons
tout à la fois être fiers et être digne
notre histoire ce n'est pas notre passé
notre histoire c'est notre avenir
la seule façon d'organiser l'avenir de
l'europe c'est de la réconcilier avec
son passé pour lui donner à nouveau
l'audace de se projeter vers les
lendemains
c'est cette europe donc je veux c'est ce
combat que je vous demande de relever
dans cette campagne il ya quelque chose
qui est en train de bouger
il y à un moment électrique qui est en
train de s'installer il y à des
pronostics qui sont en train de se
déjouer il y à ce moment que l'on
connaît tous les commentateurs tout d'un
coup sont ébahis et en se disant tiens
quelque chose se passe là où nous ne
l'attendions pas oui il y a un espoir
qui est en train de se lever de notre
côté ce moment c'est le nôtre et demain
ce sera une force que personne ne pourra
arrêter
il vous reste 24 jours pour tout donner
vingt-quatre jours pour amplifier cette
dynamique 24 jours pour dénouer tous les
pronostics
vingt-quatre jours pour mener le seul
combat qui vaille celui qui permet de se
battre tout à la fois on refonde et
l'europe et rétablir la france je ne
connais pas de plus beau combat
quand on s'engage en politique nous
avons besoin de vous vive le roi et vive
la france
[Applaudissements]